مساء الخير
هل تعرفون من القائل؛
"لقد أُنتدبت للعيش مع هؤلاء العرب
كغريب عاجز عن مجاراتهم في التفكير والمعتقد،
مجبرا على تدريبهم وتوجيههم
في الإتّجاه الّذي يتّفق مع مصالح بريطانيا المتحاربة مع عدوّهم.
وإذا كنت قد عجزت عن تفحّص شخصيتهم،
فقد نجحت على الأقلّ في إخفاء شخصيتي عنهم،
وإستطعت أن أندمج كليّا في حياتهم
دون إحتجاج ولا إنتقاد.
وبما أنّني كنت رفيقهم
فلن أحاول اليوم وقد عدت إلى إرتداء الزي البريطاني
الثناء عليهم أو الدفاع عنهم.
بل سأحرص على أن أصوّر الأحداث كما عشتها بالفعل"
هذا القول لتوماس إدوارد لورانس،
شُهر "لورانس العرب"
في كتابه الشهير،
"أعمدة الحكمة السبعة".
كتاب" أعمدة الحكمة السبعة"
لضابط المخابرات الإنجليزي توماس إدوارد لورانس
سيكون موضوع حلقتنا هذا المساء.
الكتاب  سيرة ذاتية للورنس، بين عامي 1916 و1918
عندما كان عنصر ربط بين المخابرات البريطانية والقوات العربية
التي تمردت على الأتراك العثمانيين في الحجاز والشام.
في تقديمه لكتابه يُقرّ لورانس ان هذا الكتاب هو سردية شخصية
ولا يدّعي النزاهة او عدم التحيّز.
عنوان الكتاب" أعمدة الحكمة السبعة" اقتبسه الكاتب من الإنجيل
وبالتحديد  من سِفر الأمثال القائل :
" الحكمة بَنَت بيتها، ووضعت أعمدتها السبعة"،
ويرمز لورانس من خلال العنوان
الى سبعة مدن كبيرة في الشرق الأوسط
بدأ في رسم خرائطها قبل بداية الحرب العالمية الأولى.
سيكتب لورانس  كتابه في مرّة أولى سنة 1919 في باريس،
أثناء انعقاد مؤتمر السلام
وسيفقد المخطوطة في محطة قطار،
ثمّ يعيد كتابته مرة ثانية سنة 1920 في لندن،
ولكنّه وجد ان النسخة الثانية ليست في مستوى النسخة الأولى أدبيا
وتخللتها عدة أخطاء في الأحداث و في أسماء بعض الشخصيات،
فأعاد صياغته للمرّة الثالثة سنة 1922،
ولن ينشر الكتاب إلاّ سنة 1926.
إنه من الصعوبة بمكان
تحديد الجنس الأدبي لكتاب اعمدة الحكمة السبعة،
فهو يقع في نقطة التقاطع بين السيرة الذاتية،
وأدب الرحلة
والدليل العسكري.
نجد فيه كلّ أبعاد شخصية لورانس العجيبة،
نجد فيه لورانس عالم الجغرافيا ومهندس الخرائط،
ونجد فيه لورانس عالم الأثار و المستشرق
ونجد فيه لورانس الضابط العسكري
ونجد فيه كذلك لورانس القارئ الموسوعي والكاتب ذا القلم الساحر
الذي يروي لنا أحداث الثورة العربية الكبرى بحبكة قصصية رائعة.
القارئ لأعمدة الحكمة السبعة
سيقف على أثر مؤلفات كل الكتّاب
الذين ألهموا لورنس في كتابة هذه الملحمة،
سيقف على أثر هكذا تكلّم زرادشت للفيلسوف الألماني فريدريك نيتشه،
وسيقف على أثر رواية سلامبو للكاتب الفرنسي غوستاف فلوبير،
الذي تحدّث فيها عن تمرّد الجنود المرتزقة في قرطاج،
وسيقف على أثر ملحمة الحرب والسلم للكاتب الروسي تولستوي،
وسيقف خاصّة
على أثر كتاب "ترحال في صحراء الجزيرة العربية"،
للشاعر والرحالة  الإنجليزي الشهير تشارلز مونتاڨيو دوتى.
في البداية سنحدد الإطار التاريخي للأحداث التي صوّرها الكتاب
والمدوّنة بقلم لورانس بدقة متناهية،
باليوم والشهر طيلة الفترة الممتدة بين سنتي 1916 و1918.
بعد سنتين من اندلاع الحرب العالمية الأولى،
وبالتحديد في العاشر من حزيران (يونيو) 1916،
أطلق الشريف الحسين بن علي والي مكّة
الرصاصة الأولى من شرفة قصره إيذاناً بقيام الثورة العربية الكبرى ضد الأتراك،
موكلا قيادة الثورة المسلّحة لابنائه الأربعة؛
علي، وعبد الله، وفيصل وزيد.
تمرّد الشريف حسين على الباب العالي جاء بعد مراسلاته السرية مع هنري مكماهون،
المفوض السامي البريطاني في القاهرة،
حيث تعهّد البريطانيون للعرب بضمان استقلالهم
والدفاع عن حقهم في تقرير مصيرهم
مقابل دعمهم للتاج البريطاني ضد العثمانيين
المتحالفين مع عدوتهم ألمانيا خلال الحرب العالميّة الأولى.
القيادة البريطانية ستكلّف توماس ادوارد لورنس،
ضابط المخابرات في قسم الخرائط لدى القيادة العليا للجيوش البريطانيّة في القاهرة
بمهمّة تأطير الثورة العربية في الحجاز.
أوّل مهمّات لورنس ستكون اختيار قائد للثورة العربية
من بين أبناء الشريف حسين الأربعة.
في كتابه أعمدة الحكمة السبعة يتحدّث عن أبناء الشريف حسين فيقول:
لقد عمل الحسين على ان تكون ثقافة أولاده عامة طيبة،
وعندما عادوا إلى الحجاز كأفندية
يرتدون الملابس الأوروبية متطبعين بطباع الأتراك
امرهم بارتداء الملابس العربية
وعيّن لهم مرافقين من أهل مكّة
وأرسل بهم إلى البادية مع قوى الهجانة لحماية الحجيج
كي يتقنوا اللغة العربية.
لورانس بعد ان التقى بأبناء الشريف حسين الأربعة،
سيختار ابنه الثالث فيصل ليكون زعيما للثورة العربية،
يقول لورانس:
وما كاد نظري يقع على فيصل حتى أيقنت
ان هذا هو الشخص الذي جئت بلاد العرب لأبحث عنه.
وآمنت بأنه الزعيم الذي سيسير بالثورة العربية إلى هدفها المنشود.
أيقن العقيد توماس ادوارد لورانس،
ان تفكيك لغز العرب يمرّ حتما عبر فهم ألغاز الصحراء،
لأنّ هذه الصحراء المترامية الأطراف هي التي شكّلت الشخصيّة العربيّة.
أدرك هذا الغريب نفسيّة العرب البدو المتوجّسة من الآخر،
فتكلّم لغتهم، وحفظ لهجاتهم،
ولبس لباسهم وأحبّ الصحراء القاسية مثلهم،
وحمل راياتهم وأصبح العقل المدبّر في جيش الأمير "فيصل".
يتحدّث لورنس في كتابه اعمدة الحكمة السبعة عن العرب فيقول:
والعرب شعب الإنفعالات و الثورات والإلهامات الروحية،
وعنصر العبقريات الفردية،
وأكبر صناعات العرب هي صنع المعتقدات التي تكاد تكون احتكارا لهم.
العرب يرون العالم في ألوانه الأصلية،
بل في لونيه الرئيسيين،
الأبيض والأسود
وفكرهم الجازم يحتقر الشكّ
ولا يقبل مطلقا التردد الذي تسلحنا به نحن الأوروبيين
لمواجهة شؤون ما وراء الطبيعة،
كما يأبى القبول بقلقنا النفسي،
هذا الأسود والأبيض للنظرة العربية نجده في عالمي الروح والفكر.
وبسبب الأسود والأبيض يحب هذا الشعب الجلاء والوضوح.
وهذا الشعب ذو الأفق الضيّق في التفكير
يمكنه ان يترك العقل جانبا
وينقاد بصورة عفوية وراء حب الإستطلاع،
خياله خصب ولكنه ليس خلاّقا.
لورنس سيتحدّث في كتابه عن قسوة  الصحراء وجمالها في آن واحد،
كتاب اعمدة الحكمة السبعة  سيحوّل الصحراء إلى مشاهد تصويرية غاية في الروعة.
سيتحدّث عن علاقة العرب بالماء جوهر الوجود،
هذا العنصر النادر في الصحراء وهمزة الوصل بينهم وبين السماء،
وكيف ان من عاداتهم عندما يتنقلون في الصحراء
اذا وصلوا إلى بئر ماء يشربون منها حتّى التقيؤ،
ويبقون بعد ذلك دون شراب حتى يصلوا إلى البئر الثانية.
وإذا كانوا يحملون معهم ماء فسرعان ما يُلقون به عند أول استراحة بعد ارتحالهم عن البئر الأولى
ويحملهم حدس الحياة إلى البئر الموالية.
سيروي قصصا حول آفاعي  الصحراء وثعابينها،
وكيف انه يستحيل سحب الماء من الآبار ليلا،
لأن الأفاعي تلجأ إليها لتسبح أو لتنام.
سيتحدّث عن قدرة الإبل العجيبة وطاقتها على الصبر
وكيف يمكنها قطع مسافة 150 ميلا دون ان تشرب،
أي مسيرة ثلاثة أيام.
سيحدثنا عن ناقته الفريدة التي اهداه اياها الأمير فيصل وتُدعى غزالة،
والتي استطاع ان يقطع على متنها  مسافة 134 ميلا في يوم واحد.
لورانس يقول ان العرب يثقون بالأشخاص ولا يثقون بالمؤسسات،
لذلك رأوا فيّ عميلا حرّا للحكومة البريطانية،
وطلبوا منّي تطبيق تلك الوعود المكتوبة من قبل حكومتي
والمتمثلة في إقامة دولة مستقلة في الجزيرة العربية وبلاد الشام و العراق،
على أن تكون تلك الدولة مدعومة وحليفة للتاج البريطاني.
اعتمد العقيد لورانس في حربه ضد القوات التركية على ما سُمي في ما بعد بحرب العصابات،
وهي حرب غير نظامية،
تُستخدم فيها مجموعات صغيرة من المقاتلين الكمائن، والتخريب، والغارات المفاجئة،
لذلك يرى بعض الخبراء العسكريين
أنّ لورانس هو المؤسس لهذا التكتيك العسكري في بداية القرن العشرين.
هذا الضابط البريطاني
سوف يحوّل
ثقافة الغزو وقطع الطرق والسلب السائدة بين مختلف القبائل والعشائر العربية في الصحراء
إلى سلاح ضدّ الأتراك
وسيستهدف بالأساس خط الحجاز الحديدي.
خط الحجاز الحديدي،
هو اهم مشروع انجزته الدولة العثمانية
في المنطقة العربية في بداية القرن العشرين،
تمّ انجازه بأمر من السلطان العثماني عبد الحميد الثاني
وتحت إشراف المهندس الألماني هاينريش مايسنر
واستغرقت أشغاله ثمان سنوات فقط من 1900 إلى 1908.
الخط يربط بين المدينة المنوّرة ودمشق
ويمتدّ على مسافة 1320 كلم،
ويختصر الوقت اللازم لرحلة الحج
من دمشق إلى المدينة إلى خمسة أيام فقط
عوضا عن أربعين يوما على ظهور الإبل،
وكذلك يحمي الحجيج من حوادث النهب والسرقة
التي كانوا يتعرضون لها.
لكن هذا الخط الحديدي سيُثير سُخط البدو العرب
الذين كانوا يؤجّرون إبلهم للحجيج للوصول الى مكة،
ويؤمنون حماية قوافلهم من قطاع الطرق،
إلى جانب ان خطّ الحجاز سيتسبب في انتشار الأوبئة في الجزيرة العربية
وخاصة حمى التيفوئيد.
لورانس الخبير في زرع المتفجّرات والألغام
لن يجد صعوبة في اقناع الأمير فيصل وجنوده والقبائل العربية
بجعل خط الحجاز هدف عسكري رئيسي.
الدولة العثمانية كي تؤمّن هذا الشريان الحيوي
لوصول الإمدادات العسكرية والمؤن لجنودها في الشام والحجاز
سوف تضطرّ لسحب عشرات الآلاف من الجنود من جبهات القتال
لنشرهم  على طول سكّة الحديد لحمايتها.
أصبحت المدن الواقعة على خط الحجاز الحديدي
ساحات معارك بين الثوار العرب بقيادة لورنس والأمير فيصل والجنود الأتراك.
يتحدّث لورانس في كتابه بإعجاب شديد عن جنود الأمير فيصل  وقدرتهم القتالية،
يقول:
لم يكن بالإمكان ان يُخلق رجال أصلب من هؤلاء عودا.
فهم يقطعون المسافات الخيالية على ظهور مطاياهم يوما بعد يوم
ويسيرون حفاة الأقدام على الرمال الحارقة والصخور الحادة المدببة
ويتسلقون التلال كأنهم الماعز...
ويقول أيضا متحدّثا عن قلّة خبرتهم بالأسلحة النارية:
" لقد خُيّل إلى أولائك البدو ان الطاقة التدميرية للسلاح تقاس بالدوي الذي يحدثه.
فهم لم يكونوا يخافون الرصاص ولا يهابون الموت،
غير ان منظر الموت بالقنابل كان منظرا لا يطاق بالنسبة إليهم.
لذلك اعتقدت ان الوسيلة الوحيدة لرفع معنوياتهم
هي الحصول على مدافع ذات دوي هائل.
وعندما أخبرتهم بنبأ إنزال مدافع هويتزر
في رابغ فرحوا جميعا لهذا النبأ وهللوا.
لورنس القائد العسكري
سيمتثل لأعراف هؤلاء البدو في إدارة الخلافات بينهم على جبهة القتال.
يروي في كتابه اعمدة الحكمة السبعة مصير احد مقاتليه،
حامد المغربي، بعد ان قتل رفيق له في السلاح من بني عقيل إثر شجار حاد بينهما
وكان عليه ان ينفّذ فيه حكم الإعدام بنفسه،
يقول:
عَقدتُ فورا محكمة للنظر في جريمته،
وقد اعترف بأنه قد حدثت بينه وبين القتيل ملاسنة أغضبته
وجعلته دون ما وعي يمسك بندقيته ويطلق عليه النار.
وقد طالب بني عقيل بوصفهم أقارب المغدور برأس حامد،
وقد حاولت عبثا ان اثنيهم عن عزمهم ولكن دون جدوى.
لذلك لم اجد بدا من ان أخبر حامدا بانه عليه ان يلاقي جزاء عمله.
وقد أخذت على عاتقي تنفيذ حكم الإعدام فيه.
يذكر لورانس كذلك ان جيش الشريف حسين
الذي كان يحارب الأتراك على عدّة جبهات بقيادة أبنائه
كان جيشا عربيا وليس حجازيا فحسب،
ضمّ ضباطا سوريين وحجازيين،
وعراقيين ومصريين
انشقوا عن الجيش التركي العثماني ليدافعوا عن حق العرب في تقرير مصيرهم.
يقول لورنس:
ادهشتني الروح القومية لرجال العشائر العربية
فعندما أطرح عليهم سؤال:
تُرى بعد انتصار الثورة هل تحكم دمشق الحجاز؟ أو يحكم الحجاز دمشق؟
جوابهم كان ان هذه المسألة لا تعنيهم كثيرا،
المهم ان يتخلّص العرب من الأتراك.
ويقول كذلك  لم ألمس سوى أثر ضئيل للتعصب الديني بين العرب.
ولقد رفض الشريف حُسين مرارا وتكرارا ان يضفي على ثورته رداء دينيا.
لذلك كان جوهر ثورته جوهرا قوميا.
فالعشائر كانت تعرف ان الأتراك مسلمون، والإنجليز مسيحيون.
ومع ذلك ثاروا على الأتراك وقبلوا التحالف مع المسيحيين.
أشكركم جزيل الشكر على المتابعة،
اتوقف عند هذا الحد لأعود لكم في الأسبوع القادم
مع الجزء الثاني لهذه القراءة لكتاب أعمدة الحكمة السبعة
لتوماس إدوارد لورانس.
إلى اللقاء على قناة أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود...